what uh what Chinese songs did you like
uh the Wang FEI Hong song
[Music]
trying to think about this what is
what's a song that represents strongly
represents a core memory in your life
where every time you hear it you're back
at that like Korean Bailey Ray oh
[Applause]
so there's a few there's a few more
that's such a good question that is a
good question where does that go say uh
can you sing it and then tell us the
memory dude yeah sing it just like a
star in the sky huh Korean Uncle version
no no at least one line just that line
well you should ask me to say before I
drink so alcohol saps your [__] voice
or or alcohol gives you the courage yeah
but what is this what does the melody
even sound like so just like a star
Christmas this guy something yeah
it's specifically attached to my very
first girlfriend
hey man come here man are they the same
no oh we drank too much oh the power of
songs bro what song is this so Corinne
Bailey Ray hottest I had the biggest
crush on her too but she did her her
voice was so melodic right it was very
just solemn mesmerizing and so that was
that specifically attached to my very
first girl because she also had a decent
voice too and she used to say that all
the time so every time I listen to that
album I'm cheating on my wife
oh [__] oh she's English yes her husband
was a jazz oh she used to put your
records on girl hey pull your records
yeah a little pitchy yeah yeah yeah but
that one there's that and also and also
uh Kanye West uh his first album College
Dropout oh yeah is a huge part of mine
the album as a whole yeah you know what
it is man like we're not gonna talk
about Kanye West the current man who has
lost his mind no yeah it's all good we
got it you got some good takes up we're
talking about Nostalgia we're talking
about history what are the tickets did
you like from Kanye Jam stuff I'm a big
I love when he says that stuff okay
there it is
like Kanye West like his first what I
really liked about Kanye West was like
how and this is like one of his biggest
criticisms people think that he's trying
too hard but he really does take the
uncool and make it cool right the the
polo shirts the preppy [__] look he
has that album really shifted hip-hop to
another [__] Dimension 100 yeah
undeniable it took the gangster out yeah
it it was like oh I don't have to be a
gangster to be a [__] Lyricist right
because he had these [__] one-liners
that stick with me till this day I could
I could recite lyric for a lyric almost
every [__] song on that on on that
album yeah dude and like watching what
he did during that time really made it
cool to be kind of nerdy it set up this
whole thing and then there was like the
Lupe Fiasco and the Pharrell thing with
Escape yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
kicking the pushing a kick in a push and
so like those those albums and there's
probably a few other stuff like a few
Jay-Z albums that I really [__] with but
those two albums to me are the ones that
hit the most yeah
any other specific songs that are
attached to the specifically is uh you
got it bad
because that was when I uh I got kicked
out of another school and then I was
crying and I went to the military school
and then I think you know I can't see
you just listening to this from being
kicked out of school
I really do Got It Bad
um
I was telling you like I was like man
sometimes like the people that hang out
with me they get sucked into my [__] and
they get [__] up so the chick I was
dating really good student was about to
go to USC like in the debate team like
3.7 GPA that kind of chick she hangs out
with me now she doesn't go home for like
a week or two at a time we're like
[__] going across States selling e
and we're like 16 and then so like uh
when I when I got kicked out of school
and I went to that military school I
think she was like reassessing her
normal life again and she's like oh wait
I was on this track not waking up in
random people's houses so she recognized
I think she recognized it and then so
she and then we only have pay phones
there and you have to pay the call so I
would like as soon as school was over I
would talk to her on the phone for like
I don't know like 20 minutes or whatever
and one of those times she broke up with
me and then so when I hung up I was like
[__] and then you really had it bad I
was like I can't I'm like I was like can
you wait I was like can you wait till so
the weekend when I come see you oh nah
man broken hard time
at the album and then you remember those
Iowa [__] CD players I had the
[__] fuzzy things and I remember like
laying in my book
all these guys
and at that age too with the [__] CD
player after you're done you gotta
[__] restart the play button
and then you're like wait that's the
best part you hold down the [__]
rewind a little bit when you say that
you love them and you really know
hey stop shaking the bed
everything that used to matter it don't
matter no more
that's actually one of my favorite
options
that's my go-to karaoke song oh yeah
because it's the easiest Usher song
that's so sad I can see why that would
be a core memory and then I remember I
finally so I told her don't break up
with me wait till the weekend obviously
I get in trouble that week so I can't
even go home that week so I finally I'm
able to go like three weeks later I meet
up with her and you know when like
a chick like shuts the Rapport down
like you're invisible like you you go
hey babe what's going on and it's like
hey what's going on and they're just
like
what the [__] does someone just is it
snowing in this [__] I know how
you I feel dude
I would be like are you sure you don't
want a hug oh this is good this is
growth y'all this is gross I like it hey
man I'ma tell you all this I told the
story before but this is hella [__]
embarrassing there's not much of a loser
I am maybe it's just I'm drunk I'm gonna
say it again
same [__] right so my very first
girlfriend like we got into this huge
flight we're doing long distance I was
going to Riverside she was going to
Davis yeah and then we you know I knew
we weren't compatible like we were best
friends but as our relationship we just
didn't [__] mesh you know what I mean
so one day it was like 4 a.m and we're
just like are you on the phone I was
like you know what I was like I'll be
honest with you we don't match like
we're not a good couple yeah we don't
make sense I don't understand why we're
together and she went dead silent oh
right and I think that [__] either
helped her realize that what I was
saying was true but nobody said it out
loud she hung up the phone she and she
ghosted me for like two weeks two weeks
before I was going back to Sacramento to
see her
um so same [__] you see them in the
facial expression is different it's
different like they moved on or some
[__] no warmth no no nothing you
cold-hearted [__]
hey let me show you this [__] I'm gonna
reenact what I did this is how much of a
loser I wasn't actually so we're talking
right we're talking right I told this
story before but I'm a reenact it for
you guys now uh I want you to say that
we're not going to beat again anymore
and that'll show you how I react to this
We're not gonna be together no more
[Laughter]
for reals you got down on your knees oh
crap this bitch's ankles so hard but
you're the one that said that you're not
compatible I know I regretted it Joe
you turn into the guy that goes you're
the prince of samunda
just like a star
that's crazy outside her house this
one's at my house
and I was balling my eyes out dude dude
that was one of the best life
experiences for me though
yeah I collapsed like a [__] pile of
Jenga dude I just [__] clapped over
so sad bro that was one of the biggest
life lessons for me because I realized I
was such a [__] loser and I didn't
know it I didn't know it like oh you're
a [__] loser
are you a [__] and she had no warmth
to offer you in that moment oh no she
was crying in her tears were hitting the
back of my head
happy tears bro she had some heavies
oh my God Doug that was probably one of
these that's the lowest point of my life
I just brought that back up I forgot
about that [__] that would be most
people's lowest points yeah that's
pretty low however you said it you said
I was I was 19. to hit a clean gravel
like that is pretty rough bro it was bad
dude I was grabbing this girl's ankles
like like shackles
uh give me what emotion you want me to
feel or what story you want sad because
you have so many that are just like I
just feel like there are different songs
that have different memories did you
have an ATB face
yeah I'll start I'll start with another
a loser moment as well just to make sure
that we're you know in this please I
feel terrible right now oh God
first what is it
let me let me explain situations I can't
get to straight to Loser right
um You Remember the Walkman era right so
like man was a big [__] deal right so
obviously as a younger brother to my
sister I didn't get a walk man my sister
had a walk man I just desperately wanted
to also have it but if she was using it
she was using right and then one day she
got to [__] you know like get a
different Walkman or some [__] so I
finally got her old woman I was oh [__]
I'm walking I'ma bring this [__] to
elementary school but the problem is
like getting the walking is one thing
like having the right music on the
cassette that you recorded from the
radio is a whole different thing so I
didn't have any time for that [__] you
know what I mean I was going on walking
to school I just had my sister's
cassette
and her music which was three songs
Spice Girls or something I'll get back
to it so I'm going to school and I don't
give a [__] what's on it I'm just glad
that I get to rep the visual sensation
of me having a Walkman right I get to
school I'm like I gotta walk me and you
know all these other elementary school
kids like [__] it's like they accepted
me you know what I mean and then you
gotta walk but then the older kids like
fifth and sixth graders I was gonna be
third fourth grade I think fourth grade
oh no
they [__] ripped it from me they put
that [__] on lamb chops wasn't it it was
[__] Natasha Bedingfield
I don't care what they say
that was new that was that was that
wasn't around you they're like that's a
real future it was uh was it Hanson no
it was not [__] hampson I feel like
you guys are all matching stuff it's
like man that's this is it was worse for
that era really for for me to be
listening to the time it was like a
Virgin by Madonna oh my God why were you
listening to that because that was the
only song that she had on the cassette
you got [__] oh
it's a dope song it's a good song trust
me I'm not at that age at that era at
that time in that rap for myself bro
and I swear to God like the way I
imagine I saw every kid on the Block was
there you know what I mean yeah and he
was like
it's just like a version I swear
everyone's like
oh if you were good at roasting you
would have been like how the [__] would
you know [__] why are you listening of
course I wasn't gonna
but you know what I wasn't doing I
didn't fall to his [__] ankles and
have his heavy tears drop on the back of
my head yeah but at least people weren't
there to see it loser God damn I was a
loser
oh my God she had [__] handprints on
her ankles
so whenever you hear that song does It
transport you right back to that moment
first for five for five milliseconds I
laugh real quick and then I move on to
like other [__] you can imagine her
being able to do them
[Laughter]
I always wanted to do this but I will
say on a way more positive and way less
loser uh frame another Usher song just
to relate to You Usher Yeah was the
first song that I ever did a solo to in
high school for our lip sync and it made
you popular it made me popular
no no not popular because that's too
that's too high it just made me
noticeable yeah I existed for once in my
life they're like hey he's the guy that
did that at the talent show yeah
that's the core memory for me is along
the lines of that because there was this
house remix song that a friend of mine
gave me on a CD it was Elton who gave me
the CD and uh at the time like house CDs
you could only get them like word of
mouth or just from hand to hand people
like because they weren't they weren't
really Health says in like house music
yeah yeah like they didn't have Ministry
of Sound stuff that you could buy
readily available like until later so
this was like 2003 and I was a person
that would attend the dance things that
you ended up doing like Vibe ultimate
brawl Buster Groove like I was just a
person in the audience yeah for three
years and I'd never I didn't know
anybody to even start doing it but I
would always sit there and just be so
envious I'm like damn man like I wish I
could just be on that stage but you
didn't even dance you just watched no I
I just like started wow and then uh so
2003 I went to these events 2004 I went
to the event 2005 is when I finally got
to perform that was when I was in sixth
step and they gave me a solo and then
um it wasn't the song that I danced to
at all but then that's when people
finally like noticed who I was and on
the way home I put that house CD in and
there's a song called Night Lights by
Samus [__] and it's a polyphonics remix
it's such a polyphonics that's some old
school how's it Go was like the moment
that I realized this is the identity
that I want forever a dancer yeah
because I didn't know what I was that
was Usher Yeah I didn't know what I was
in the world until that moment and I
went this is my rep like from now on and
it was that moment that that song played
and it was me and Eris and hawk in the
car and we were driving back and I was
like guys this is us this is us now
that's fire [__]
that is fine uh please elaborate
[Laughter]
I was looking dope Scotland Yard yeah
and it was for some reason like I
listened they put that song on Spotify
like recently because it's such a weird
song but then it's on there and I was
like and every time I listen to it I'm
like back at that my my like youth comes
back and I'm like dude this is still me
and like it's so cool that's the
craziest connection I have Missy Elliott
that's the craziest connection I have
the music it's like you know how they
say smells tied with memory yeah for me
like some songs I actually don't just I
stay away from some errors because it
takes me so much into that world that
it's so emotionally heavy that I just
don't listen to it wow like like you get
withdrawals you're like like technology
gangster rap
like [__] yeah like anything
I remember printing the lyrics of the
Four Seasons of Loneliness as a fifth
grader and trying to remember it in
class
yo so good dude oh any Boyz II Men song
is specifically tied to the first time I
got dumped any Brian McKnight
because that that one's really like like
you're a little [__] and you're
wondering if she thinks about you dude
that second verse hits me so [__]
hard dude still have your picture in the
frame I'm like oh throw it away already
oh that [__] gets me dude and you gotta
play it back again because you gotta cry
again
and it's like all the first like
heartbreaks ever I swear I hear your
voice driving me said how [__] fire
are those lyrics dude somebody took time
someone sounds what Chinese songs did
you like uh the Wang FEI Hong song
that song was like iconic for me at the
time but like anything would have gone
yeah yeah anything like that no but any
any music my parent my dad was like
super into music he had really good
taste of music and so do my sisters so I
was like heavily influenced by like
their music I remember anytime my dad
would drive [__] Sade would always
play and smooth Operator would go
I'll be like that I don't want to listen
to this like I would just hate it as a
kid but I was like older it's just so
reminiscent of like the [__] Ford
Windstar that we used to drive you know
I mean it'd be like late nights my dad
always playing Sade and then um like a
lot of music reminds me of like my
family like uh my dad would always play
at Carlos Santana like that was his
[__] he'd be jamming at Carlos sing
with Carl Santana song right now [__]
he would always play Oh yoke
like you're always playing all that [__]
just like all kinds of [__] right he
would like he would like the [__]
he'd always play Rob Thomas and kids
Carlos like what is this and uh BG's
always reminds me my mom
like I remember my mom would always play
uh how deep is your love and she'd
always be like it always reminded me of
how she didn't love you no yeah but like
when how it was her and her mom's song
and whenever when my mom my grandmother
passed away she would always play that
song Oh Margaret she'd always think
about that and to you that was cool yeah
like he was always remind me that not my
grandpa what was another one [__] my
mom would always play Luther Vandross in
the house
bro I'm telling you baby
listening to their [__] you know how
like Grandpa would listen to [__]
Korean wailing music
like Korean whole folk music is all
about pain and destruction so it's just
them
and I will wake up in the middle of the
night
nobody's sleeping now I will say I'm
thankful to my mom for introducing me to
The Beatles via karaoke so it wasn't the
actual Beatles yeah so I knew a lot of
the midi versions no no dude I knew a
lot of The Beatles songs and lyrics and
didn't know it was the Beatles as a kid
for years because it's just a karaoke
VHS and that's what the Casio sound hey
how funny if his grandma would always
play How Deep Is Your Love but it's the
one that goes your love for me
The Dru Hill version it's not called
beetles it's called beetles
what about yours Bart was it was it just
the raving songs
they all depend oh yeah other than you
got it back Robert Miles children so all
that there's a whole trans face there's
a whole trans phase for sure uh there's
another one
um you know uh no doubt gwent
um No Doubt Sunday morning so that song
came out when I was in junior high and
in junior high spent my Summers on the
swim team and so we would swim all the
time and uh after swim practice our
coach would take us to the beach to go
like Boogie boarding or body surfing or
whatever and I remember he had like a
pretty cool Volkswagen not a bug but
like this classic car that seat pretty
much like six people it's like a bench
seat in the front so three of them it
was the van it was the van then no no it
was a sedan and I remember that uh like
all the kids would try to pack into his
car because this is back in the day
where like I guess safety wasn't that
big of an issue I think I think seat
belts were optional at the time it was
never optional but would continue really
okay but they had videos on that about
you specifically not doing that or you
would die it was it was called red
asphalt but continue here and the
dummies but continue but the chick that
was half white half asian that I had a
crush on was sitting next to me like I
always wanted to sit next to her in our
car ride to the beach and then I was
like [__] it's never it never happens
it's never in this Arrangement sometimes
we would talk when we're in swim
practice and then like sometimes like I
don't even know if she knows my name and
then I remember being in the car with
her windows down going hunting the beach
this song comes on all of us know the
lyrics so we're all just singing along
to it and like I remember getting all
these Goosebumps because we're like
literally like this
so just that puppy love feeling is is
attached to full boners dude that's the
Korean Bailey red thing the Sunday
morning song
I'm gonna listen to every song that was
mentioned here on the way home yeah
Corinne Bailey raised especially yeah
I'm gonna play it out that whole album
with that the one that whole album dude
finds a seal a kisser this needs a part
too
with Geo in it she'll probably name
every freaking song on Earth
nobody knows he knows about me